they're long and slithery and they're
not very colorful but they do have a
strange beauty of their own their
sinuous nocturnal movements through the
water are mesmerizing to watch and
though they may resemble underwater
snakes
eels are in fact a very interesting type
of fish there are several things about
eels that make them unique besides their
elongated shape and limbless bodies for
one thing eels have the ability to
breathe through their skin some can even
leave the water and move over land for
short periods an unlike most migratory
fish such as salmon which spawn in
freshwater but live their adult lives in
saltwater eels of the genus Anguilla
migrate in the opposite direction
spawning and breeding in oceans and seas
while spending most of their intervening
time in freshwater if we were to take
one such freshwater eel and follow its
life story it would be born in the
middle of the North Atlantic Ocean about
a thousand miles east of Bermuda this
area called the Sargasso Sea forms the
western part of a subtropical gyre a
giant whirlpool in the middle of the
ocean our eel let's call it Eli
would begin as one of ten to 20 million
tiny eggs carried by a female eel
hatching into a transparent leaf shaped
thing that looks nothing like an adult
eel
elie starts to drift in ocean currents
predominantly the Gulf Stream towards
either Europe or North America depending
on its particular species
upon reaching the coast Eli is about two
inches long
looking more eally but still transparent
known at this stage as a glass eel but
within a couple of days and fresh water
Eli's skin becomes pigmented a brownish
black now looking more like that of an
adult eel you might notice that we
haven't mentioned anything about Eli's
gender yet that's because this is only
determined once an eel enters freshwater
though nobody is sure exactly how that
happens most of the eels that stay in
the estuaries in brackish water become
males while those that go upstream
become females growing up to two to
three times bigger than their future
mates in this case it turns out that Eli
was actually short for Elaine as a
female eel Elaine will be quite solitary
for most of her life in the stream
eating whatever falls in the water
grasshoppers crickets small fish insect
larvae frogs baby birds
almost anything she can get her mouth
around and she will grow quite big up to
four feet long and weighing as much as
13 pounds we don't know exactly how
freshwater eels know when it's time to
return to the ocean but something calls
to them and their fall migration is one
of the largest unseen migrations on the
planet as Elaine leaves fresh water for
the ocean she undergoes a shocking
metamorphosis her eyes and large by
about ten times her skin gets thicker
and her fins get larger these are most
likely adaptations for their upcoming
ocean travel and Elaine seamlessly makes
the transition from fresh to saltwater
which would be toxic for most other fish
once Elaine leaves the mouth of the
freshwater streams she will disappear
completely from human view no one has
witnessed or been able to follow an
adult eel on their migration nor do we
know how deep they spawn but it's
assumed that they can follow some signs
that they can detect such as a thermal
barrier between ocean currents or a
salinity front in order to return to the
same area of the ocean where they were
born because we don't even know exactly
what happens during an eel migration we
can only imagine what the actual
breeding looks like but the common
hypothesis is that Elaine and that
thousands or hundreds of thousands of
other eels gather in large intertwined
masses and release their eggs and sperm
in a giant orgy known as pan mix eeeh a
couple of days after the eggs are laid
they hatch and the cycle begins again
and because we've never seen the adult
eels returning up the freshwater rivers
we must assume that having completed
their long and roundabout journey these
amazing and mysterious creatures finally
died there in the same place where they
were born goodbye Elaine it was a
pleasure knowing you
you